Olá tudo bem Aqui o Dr Alan Machado
Dutra médico há mais de 25 anos e hoje
eu vou falar sobre a qualidade da
creatina Será que você está sendo
enganado uma análise recente mostrou que
diversas marcas de creatina no mercado
foram reprovadas no teste de teor de
creatina ou seja o que estava no rótulo
não correspondia ao que realmente estava
no pote e algumas apresentaram 100% de
variação o que significa esses produtos
continham qualquer coisa menos creatina
imagina só você comprando o suplemento
achando que vai turbinar o seu treino
ajudar na sua saúde e na verdade está
levando
farinha Pois é pessoal complicadíssimo a
creatina é um dos Suplementos mais
populares e Mais estudados atualmente
ela é um verdadeiro destaque quando se
trata de nutrição esportiva e saúde
geral e olha os benefícios da creatina
não são só para atletas de Elite não até
quem faz atividades físicas leves
especialmente os idosos podem se
beneficiar muito a creatina é super
mencionada quando a gente fala sobre
envelhecer com qualidade e sabe por quê
Porque ela ajuda na prevenção de doenças
crônicas protege contra a depressão
ajuda no ganho de massa muscular e ajuda
a evitar a perda de massa muscular em
idosos O que é essencial para manter o
corpo forte e saudável conforme
envelhecemos Mas vamos à questão das
marcas de creatina de acordo com uma
matéria feita pelo Portal de Notícias
Metrópolis a Associação Brasileira das
empresas de produtos nutricionais a
abenutri fez uma análise de várias
marcas de criatina disponíveis no
mercado e de acordo com essa análise os
resultados foram preocupantes de todas
as marcas testadas 25 foram reprovadas
no quesito teor de creatina ou seja o
que estava escrito no rótulo não batia
com que realmente tinha dentro do pote
dessas 25 marcas 10 apresentaram 100% de
variação isso quer dizer que esses
produtos continham qualquer coisa menos
creatina dentro aqui na tela você vai
ver a lista dessas marcas que tiveram
100% de variação
importante ficar de olho nisso a
variação máxima permitida é de 20% da
quantidade creatina especificada no
rótulo ou seja o produto precisa ter
pelo menos 80% de Pureza para ser
considerado confiável agora está
aparecendo aí na sua tela a lista das
marcas reprovadas e os percentuais de
cada uma acima do normal é importante
salientar que segundo a AB nutre as
empresas suplay fabricante das marcas
probiótica e Max Titanium
inab das marcas age Monster feed intab e
Cel e brg integral médica e darkness
tiveram seus produtos testados porém
entraram com medidas jurídicas para não
divulgação dos resultados agora escolher
um suplemento de qualidade não é só uma
questão de alcançar melhores resultados
nos treinos ou competições Mas também de
cuidar da sua saú saúde geral uma
creatina de baixa qualidade pode não ser
só ineficaz como também prejudicial à
saúde o laudo da benutri segundo a
matéria também apontou as marcas que
apresentaram conformidade em relação à
presença de 80% ou mais de creatina
essas marcas que estão aparecendo agora
na sua tela representam as que tiveram
menos de 20% de variação entre o que
está declarado no rótulo e o que
realmente contém no pote então todas
essas na sua tela são marcas que foram
aprovadas pessoal vamos falar sobre a
importância de escolher uma creatina de
qualidade a ingestão de produtos que não
correspondem ao
anunciado pode levar a frustração e até
problemas de saúde devido à ausência dos
benefícios esperados e a exposição a
ingredientes desconhecidos uma forma de
garantir a pureza da sua creatina é
procurar pelo selo creapure este selo
indica que a creatina passou por um
rigoroso processo de purificação
garantindo 100% de Pureza e alta
qualidade não adianta estar só escrito
no rótulo que é 100% creatina é preciso
ter esse selo que aparece na sua tela
agora a creatina com selo creapure tem
uma textura bem fina sua absorção é
maior tornando-a uma das melhores opções
de creatina disponíveis existem
diferentes formas de creatina como a
etil Ester e a hidroclor hídrica no
entanto as formas mais conhecidas e
consumidas são a monoidratada e a
micronizada a creatina monoidratada é a
mais estudada e utilizada sendo uma
escolha segura e eficaz PR a maioria das
pessoas ela é frequentemente indicada
devido aos seus comprovados benefícios
já a creatina micronizada é uma versão
mais nada o que pode facilitar a
dissolução mas não há estudos que
comprove um melhor efeito em relação à
mono hidratada aqui vai uma dica procure
marcas conhecidas no mercado e avalie a
lista de ingredientes no verso do
produto optando por aquelas que sejam
mais puras e evitando suplementos com
aditivos desnecessários como corantes
aromatizantes e conservantes o preço
pode variar significativamente entre as
diferentes marcas e formas de creatina
mesmo que o produto mais barato pareça
mais atraente lembre-se de que a
qualidade e a eficácia são fundamentais
considere o custo por dose e compare a
reputação da marca a lista que eu
mostrei na tela no começo sobre a
qualidade do produto se tem selo
creapure tudo isso para determinar o
melhor custo
benefício Outro ponto importante ao
escolher a creatina é prestar atenção na
solubilidade em água a creatina pura
deve se dissolver completamente mesmo
que demore um pouco mais caso contrário
isso pode indicar baixa qualidade
creatinas puras e de alta qualidade
costumam ter um pó mais fino branco e
homogêneo sinais de imperfeições ou
texturas diferentes podem indicar
impurezas no
produto pessoal eu adoro a creatina e
como disse no início ela tem vários
benefícios além do ganho de músculo em
especial eu gosto muito os benefícios
para as mulheres eu vou falar
rapidamente sobre eles mas eu recomendo
que assistam ao meu vídeo completo sobre
a suplementação de creatina eu vou
deixar esse link na descrição a creatina
é uma substância natural produzida pelo
nosso corpo e está relacionada com o
aumento de energia ela é composta por
três aminoácidos glicina arginina e
metionina além de ser produzida pelo
fígado a creatina é encontrada em peixes
e carnes vermelhas a creatina aumenta a
força e a potência muscular mesmo se
você não for atleta ajudando na
construção de músculos mais fortes e
saudáveis ela melhora o metabolismo
aumenta a produção de energia e faz o
treino render mais além de melhorar o
desempenho físico a creatina é usada
para tratar doenças musculares como A
distrofia e a fibromialgia mulheres no
período menstrual na gravidez no
pós-parto ou na pós-menopausa também se
beneficio do consumo de creatina e mesmo
que você não faça atividade física
constante os benefícios da creatina são
amplos ela aumenta a produção de energia
no
cérebro melhora a função cognitiva e
pode ajudar em doenças como Parkinson a
creatina pode prevenir doenças crônicas
como diabetes e doenças cardíacas
melhorar a densidade óssea e combater a
perda de massa muscular e óssea
especialmente idosos se sua mãe ou avó
estão na pós-menopausa a creatina pode
ser importante no tratamento da perda de
massa muscular e óssea prefira a
creatina monoidratada que é mais eficaz
e mais estudada a dose recomendada de
três a 5 G ao dia e não há horário
preferencial para tomar mas algumas
pessoas relatam insônia quando consom à
noite também interessante combinar a
creatina com carboidratos e proteínas
carboidratos complexos veja lá não vai
tomar com açúcar
[Música]
Muito obrigado pela sua atenção um
grande abraço e um beijo no seu coração
você é Fea